Um,
thank you very much for tuning in and thank you all for your support.
And um,
keep
what else?
I hope that
I have lots of plans for 2018 and I would like to keep you all in the loop.
And so all post a lot of those.
Oh yes.
I should tell you this.
I'm going to be giving some public talks,
a bunch of them.
So I'm going to be in the following places in January,
February and March.
Um,
I'll try to say them in order.
I'm going to be in London and then I'm going to be in Amsterdam and then I'm
going to be in New York,
Los Angeles,
San Francisco,
maybe Oakland.
Then I'm going to be in a bunch of cities across Canada and major cities,
Winnipeg,
Edmonton,
Ottawa,
Calgary,
maybe this little town,
grand prairie that I went to college in Vancouver.
And then I'm going to go down to Australia and I'm going to go to Melbourne and
Sydney and Brisbane.
And so I'll post
the dates on my website very soon.
I've,
I'm still making the arrangements.
And so if you want to come and listen to me talk,
then you'll have the opportunity to do so and so.
Okay.
So I have to say good night.
And so good night to all of you.
And,
uh,
what would I like to compose with?
Well,
I'm glad you're tuning in and I hope that you're using the information that
you're finding as a consequence of tuning in to put your lives together,
because it would really be good in 2018 if a whole bunch of people did
everything they could to put their lives together because then maybe we could
avoid this idiot catastrophe that we seem to be dreadfully sliding towards.
And so that would be lovely if we could just not do that.
So until next time,
bye bye.